oh you can't
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody dope is y'all
here hope you're having a dope ass day
[ __ ] can we run back i started it like a
[ __ ] youtube video
what's up everybody how's everybody
doing this is the dope as usual podcast
i hope you guys are having a great day
if you're driving please be safe
if you're at home chilling welcome to
the show either way guys
thank you so much this is the podcast
we're here to talk about life
accomplishments
problems drugs and everything in between
today
we have a very special guest the most
requested person of all
[ __ ] time no lie guys this you guys
won't
[ __ ] stop tagging us i promise you we
see it
we see it i promise you see every single
one for sure here it is guys here it is
the
the person you've all been waiting for
eric khan thank you so much dude thank
you so much for being here
thank you so much for having me man
thank you so much great introduction to
l.a thank you bro
for being here eight days nine days
maybe
you hear that he moved here eight days
ago
oh glad to go experience i love it it's
like one of my first things on the
checklist and i'm glad i got to check it
off right now
this is dope we [ __ ] started off with
the dev sorry i'm i'm
i'm [ __ ] high rick is awesome as [ __ ]
dude
thank you love that little thing so real
quick straight before we start
for maybe out there like i don't know
who this person is this is a different
audience
maybe they're not a weed audience what
do you do what
what if someone asks you what do you do
for work
what do you say because it's hard right
that's funny because when i was in texas
i used to tell them different things
so yeah i would do like videography or
marketing i'd say marketing a lot
it's kind of weird because it would you
you would get different um reactions so
when i started marketing yeah [ __ ]
okay bro especially when i got my car
people would just like normally ask me
hey what do you do like you're so young
like how do you drive this [ __ ]
and then you would get different
reactions so i would say like youtuber a
couple of times and they'd be like you
know in the little snarf like off
like you said one youtuber like youtuber
oh so they'd be like off
like yeah whatever like youtuber and
then you would say marketing and they're
like oh yeah like i could see yeah okay
i could see that you're like yeah a
little something on top i do multiple
things then you could say like
entrepreneur like i own a business and
then they're like just super wet about
it and it's [ __ ] it's weird to see
the difference
yeah it's super weird to know like see
the difference when it's all just like
yeah you say youtuber to most people
like what the [ __ ] you talking about
exactly it's it's hard i mean because
you do more than youtube too
now you have your own business so how'd
you get into that i i think it's awesome
you everybody should that's doing videos
and has a following
start something that's more than
yourself that's almost exactly what it
was
it was the whole premise behind it was
like oh my god
uh the whole premise behind it was like
i wanted to create something that
people love that wasn't like erican that
didn't have like a face of mine to it
type [ __ ] you know what i mean that have
like
you like the products you like the
company you like the brand the vision
whatever without knowing who the ceo is
or who
runs it like someone sends you the image
someone sends you the page someone sends
you their little product and then you're
like
that's dope like i want to buy that i
don't care who made it you know what i
mean so that's what
i kind of like the vision behind the
whole brand was and it's called a no
how do you say it anova nova i did say
right okay anova
so you're selling i mean i saw your
dabbers and all your stuff that you're
starting to sell
is it how are you curating this [ __ ]
i know it's like it's like marble on the
right on one of your down i thought yeah
that was very [ __ ] cool i like that a
lot thank you thank you the whole
premise behind it is like
bringing really nice glass to an
audience that might not like it and
like a relatively affordable price point
because a lot of people are smoking just
really china glass really cheaply made
glass it's probably like
kind of bad labor maybe bad ethics bad
whatever behind it but this whole brand
premise is like
you can get accessories you can get
really dope one-off things or really
rare things
that are made proudly like in america by
these artists like by hand like they're
trying to like come up and that's where
the collaboration comes on because they
really want to like
i have artists that i hit up and that's
really how it sources so i have a page
on my section
i have a section on my page that's like
if you're an artist hit me up you want
to collab and that's how i source a
little bit of the collaboration
yeah but a lot of it is like just
hitting dms it's like yo dude i really
like what you do like i spend hours a
day just on instagram like looking
[ __ ] that's super cool glass and like
what kind of like the vision that i want
and i'll just dm them hey do you do
wholesale are you down to like do this
and then let's like split a little
something and it's like yeah and i just
line up like week by week by week and i
have like hella inventory set up and
these artists are just like
yo that's so smart because you don't
have to have a [ __ ] warehouse you
don't have to have nothing like that yes
dude i just use i use my garage for a
while
at my apartment and that's no that's how
it starts that's how we started yeah i
took a picture of it
i remember there's a there's a photo of
like jeff bezos working in like a garage
in a crush yeah yeah in his little panda
that sounds like
experience when i take this little
picture yeah i'm saying like you
essentially you're the one that's
got it yeah since you're the one that's
uh
basically collabing with these people to
get it out to the masses because you
have the audience and you're like well i
[ __ ] with that heavily how can we get
that more affordable for people
right it's a win-win for both sides yes
exactly
and they get their art like that's the
whole thing like they want the exposure
too you know they want their art seen by
more people like who doesn't like
they're really proud of their stuff
yeah exactly so it's like the people get
what they want at a good price
they get exposed to more awesome glass
they might have not have been exposed to
before they expose these artists it
helps these artists like
make a living if they're trying to do
that or if they already do like gives
him a nice order
it's like i think it's a win-win for
everybody you know yeah
sick do you say i didn't know that
because when i saw you coming out with
so many things i'm like
[ __ ] you have to manufacture all this
[ __ ] yeah no
that's why i was like you don't have to
have a [ __ ] lathe you don't have to
do that
that's the way to start because then
eventually you'll have everybody does
the home
the home product right some in-house
like you have a product that's actually
gonna have to eventually because it's
gonna get
to a point where it's popular enough
where people want i don't know what
about the basic one and that's how
supreme started
right yeah see the whole thing sorry
this whole i just completed like the
preseason i want to say of anova which
is like the weekly drops instead so the
season one is going to be
the but i really wanna yeah yeah i like
that thank you thank you so the whole
season the whole um like the shebang of
what i want to know to be is really a
streetwear brand because i'm going to
come out with some like crazy clothing
uh actually attila helped me out source
it so a guy
good [ __ ] yeah yeah he's uh making some
really dope clothing like exactly how i
want it like exactly like stitching the
size to fit like every single thing that
i can detail yes exactly
and um i wanted to create a brand almost
like kith which is one of my favorite
brands or like supreme or something
where they have
super dope accessories and you like
those but like the clothing stuff you
know what i mean
it's like so that's the brand start yeah
it's going to be sick
yeah that's the first thing i noticed
when you were wearing that mm-hmm thank
you yeah they make bombshell and you're
the
one of the few people i see that
constantly rocks it yeah ronnie figg is
like the little ceo of his and i really
rock with like his vision i saw some
stuff with it back in the day and i was
like
he's dope like i wanna he's like a big
inspiration for sure
yeah i wanted to talk to you about that
because i know so many there's so many
people that follow us between both of us
and probably the same crowd too but
there's so many people that follow us
and i mean you probably get thousands of
comments i want to start this that would
be cool i think i have an idea for a
business
you just started it right yeah just went
for it you just have to go for it and
just try it yeah it was just like [ __ ]
it
it's a perfect thing like i did with the
clothes like let's just try it let's
just try and you have to keep trying
keep trying
exactly 100 if you're not successful
right off the bat like crazy
successful you don't have to be down and
be like oh this is not going to work
it takes time but you have a built-in
following too
so it's like you're seizing the perfect
opportunity a hundred percent how many
products come with the
occult following already you know what i
mean like
it works yeah right it's pretty [ __ ]
awesome dude like having people just
support you like that you know it's like
a crazy feeling like what yeah it's
[ __ ]
and then it's weird to be able to talk
to somebody else that go like hey you
know what
i'm talking about right you know when
people do this [ __ ] oh yeah
of course it's because it's a rare thing
to be able to like what do you do
ah it's not complicated yeah do a couple
things do a
few things mainly what i'm known for is
smoking weed
or how did you get the start because
marty was literally asking me like so
how long has been you on youtube like
you know what
let's just talk to him let's just talk
to him and ask exactly because i know
people
how many times have you done like a
story and then three months later some
for eight months straight they're asking
about that what you answered
like actually there's a video i just put
out and you feel like you're going to
feel like a dick for saying but you're
like it's not your fault but yeah just
check this video out it explains the
whole thing
yeah yeah so for people that haven't
done that or haven't got the answer back
or
what did you do how did you start this i
know you're just like all of us smoking
weed in high school
doing your thing right it has to i mean
that's where everyone stems from
and then what did you do because you're
you're in a new you're in a different
like generation than i am
right is your health 22. see yeah 22 i'm
31.
and i know it's like it seems
like not that long but it is a long time
dude yes
two high schools yeah that's two high
school classes yeah
it's [ __ ] funny it's definitely it's
a long time so
you grew up in the oh [ __ ] youtube is an
actual viable thing to make money
because when i was a kid just like
rotten.com and [ __ ] e-bombs world
right so did you see yourself smoking
weeding oh you know what i think i can
make a video
and maybe fun to start doing [ __ ] or do
you just make a video and go [ __ ] people
like this
almost like that so it actually started
i'd say like the first time i ever made
a video was actually in eighth grade
and it was for a documentary in uh like
the history fair so everyone
you get like an option to do the history
fair and everyone is like a poster board
or like a powerpoint or whatever
but we got the option to like make a
video i was like [ __ ] i kind of like
like watch youtube all day like i feel
like i can make a dope video so i like
took some clips online
downloaded it threw it in imovie
narrated it it was about d-day
and then um yeah yeah this is super
crazy i got super into world war ii and
[ __ ]
and then my teacher was like did you
make this i was like
yeah she's like this is insane like this
is sick she was like i'm going to submit
it to like little history fair like i
run like a regional like [ __ ] award
or some [ __ ] for it and i was like yeah
and i was like damn this is kind of dope
kind of like yeah i was like okay i kind
of like making uh
like videos and stuff so um ninth grade
we do another history fair and it's
almost the same theme so i just submit
the same video
and then the teacher says the same thing
she's like did you make this like this
is insane
i did this in imovie yeah that's how i
started what the [ __ ] were you doing
that was so
bad that's cause i suck i suck at
editing dude yeah so if you're making
[ __ ] like that in eighth grade
wow i don't know i was just watching
like it was literally just imitation
almost like i would watch like three or
four of the documentaries on the same
thing and i would see how they like
transitioned or see how
long they like put the certain like
lengths on
me look down yeah and i see how like the
music comes in or comes out and i'm like
okay like it's not that hard to
replicate so that's what i did
then i got the same comments in ninth
grade so i was like [ __ ] it like i'm
gonna make some videos so i started
making
call of duty videos on another channel i
got a game play
yeah i had a video game channel where i
would like cocked and like do some
gameplay and stuff and i was honestly
sick like i was nasty at call of duty so
people watched for that and i was like
kind of funny like a goofy ass [ __ ]
14 year old just talking [ __ ]
so they're like this guy's kind of funny
whatever so i hit like almost 10
000 subscribers over the course like a
couple years and then gaming [ __ ]
yeah on the gaming stuff 14 times yeah
yeah yeah and then um
it kind of just died out and i was like
not really feeling video games anymore
by my senior year of high school so that
was over the course of like two and a
half years i was just rocking with like
video games and stuff
and then i was like i kind of want to
keep making youtube videos but like i
don't really play video games anymore
so i was like [ __ ] it what do i really
do i just smoke weed and hang out my
friends [ __ ] it i'll just record that
so i asked for a video camera for
christmas that year
and i got it and then uh i just i bought
a lens with like my own money and like
bought them like microphone and all that
setup
they're like these are expensive i was
like just give me like a use shitty one
like i don't care like i'll just [ __ ]
i'll make it work
and then um did that started uploading
videos
under like my real name because i used
like a gameplay moniker before on
youtube and then i was like [ __ ] i
gotta like
personable you know what i mean like
aircon that's my name like we'll just do
it it doesn't sound like real name it
sounds like
like a really cool villain's name
because khan
i didn't know that was your real name at
first at all until i met you yeah yeah
yeah
so uh i just did that and then i don't
know it just started to kick off after
like a year i was getting like
10 to 100 views a video for like a year
like uploading once or twice a week just
like that's
grinding you know and i mean just like
just uploading whatever the [ __ ]
just uploading whatever the [ __ ] just
super excited i have screenshots in my
phone
of like 250 subscribers 500 subscribers
like a thousand subscribers yeah i have
them all
wow it's [ __ ] it's pretty darn very
cool yeah it's pretty cool
um so that's just how it started and
then eventually it just got i think what
really popped me off there was a time
period where like custom grow and all
those youtubers were getting deleted
and i didn't get touched i don't know
why like yeah they just didn't delete me
so like when people looked up weed
content i was like one of the only ones
so that really helped out for sure that
was like an explosive they all got
deleted
permanently uh for a period yeah i think
most of them got their channels back
like after
like a year or two yeah like several
years like a lot of them quit because
they're like i'm just never getting my
channel back
and then went back to their regular [ __ ]
i don't know why they didn't do that
aren't you
all right yeah i would i guess they were
scared they'd get deleted again i mean i
wouldn't
you know after all that yeah if you're
gonna delete you're gonna delete might
as well just keep going yeah it's fun
mainly that's just fun yeah it was
stupid fun i see it at the time like i
didn't even know
when i was making my um uh
like the original question you're saying
like would you that i thought was gonna
make money from it so the gameplay
videos were getting me like a couple
hundred bucks a month in high school
which is chill as [ __ ] i was like dude i
don't gotta work a part-time job like
joking you guys like i'm doing youtube
and [ __ ] and then um i already knew that
the videos weren't going to get
monetized but i was going to college and
[ __ ] so
we're going to get monetize the gaming
the uh when i made the weed content
because i already knew like the youtube
system so i was like all right i don't
even know if there is money in this but
like i could probably make it work
somehow like if i somehow got an
audience like that was the initial
maybe the initial goal i think was like
if i somehow get an audience i want to
start a brand or i want to start
something like with that and help
nice yeah yeah and i'm finally like
realizing that vision
good [ __ ] it's like four years in the
making and then you moved to the place
to do it
exactly i just had to man i just had to
get out here dude i think i moved here
in my fifth year doing
this content where were you before uh
up north where merced yeah it's uh
you know where sacramento is california
right two hours south that's
okay it's a little town but yeah man
that you sound like you're right on the
right path right now
thank goodness yeah yeah it's great to
see that thank you man i'm
super excited about everything like it's
just dope just to be out here in l.a
like i'm doing stuff in l.a that like
never in a million years would have done
back in texas like it's crazy like
so now the question for everyone out
there that hasn't watched
i saw your video that hasn't watched one
of these videos in the past month or any
of his videos
you've been lying because when i first
met you i go so how's uh
arizona you know bro i don't live in
arizona
i was like just telling you who you're
sneaking my father
you're lying to your whole audience for
how many years
three and a half like a fat minute bro
like a fat ass and some people knew
because i would slip up sometimes and
like people would just be honest like
they'd be on your [ __ ] like there's a
water bottle that's only in texas and i
showed it on a live stream
they're like um how do you have that
that's only in texas i was like yeah you
gotta be careful
exactly yeah like low-key [ __ ] i would
have friends um that would come over and
they would say like the real time
because it's like a two-hour time
difference
and then people would be like live yeah
and they'd be like wait a minute it's
not people are good man
yes people are good i make sure to look
the whole room and it cut out
addresses off anything nice yeah yeah
definitely i mean people are [ __ ]
good dude they're looking bro they're
just waiting for you to slip up for sure
yeah i'm just a lie about where i live
downtown for so long but yeah i don't
live there and i see people in the
elevator
yo i'm out i get the dm like no i'm just
at my friend's house
yeah yeah yeah yeah then show you man
people at the place you lived
i did that once in texas and i was like
nah i'm just visiting yeah
it's not like don't follow me it's moro
you know what i have specifically all
the time you can
literally know exactly where i'm at when
i'm if you just turn my [ __ ] off
it's a scary feeling depending on what's
going on right most definitely
nice do so how's texas i mean you grew
up born and raised yeah i was born in
austin lived there for a few years and
then i started kindergarten in san
antonio and lived there since
21 i guess 22 almost so
17 years in that [ __ ] it's a crazy
little city but
so question how are you doing all this
in the legal state
i would just travel a lot i guess so i
guess one of the videos like
and the companies were kind of cool with
it they were just like i feel like the
exposure i guess like not the actual
like
drug companies you know i mean like not
the weed companies like drug companies
not the actual
for you where you're at it's a drug yeah
for sure but um yeah not the weed
companies i would have to like fly
here and make content here for that
which is why i eventually moved out here
because i was flying out so much and it
was just like
i started to get actual like weed stuff
because before it was just like glass
and stuff that was actually legal to
ship to texas
so all the devices and stuff are legal
you can get a puffco ship to texas and
all that you know what i mean no problem
but
i would literally just fly the weed back
because you know lax you can go out with
like an ounce of weed or like eight
grams of concentrate
so i would just like every trip back i
would go like twice a month late and i'd
just be like
oh [ __ ]
they never start your [ __ ] on nah good
yeah i think it's i mean uh tsa would
look at it every time and they would be
like
we do all carry-on and they would just
like open it up see it all on top like
move it around because they're just
looking for bombs and [ __ ] you know
that's crazy man he's gonna make sure
you don't have like a pack on you nearly
yeah
probably anything over qpb yeah for sure
no it's like a personal mouse you can
like fit in your hand like [ __ ] them
like they're looking for like bad [ __ ]
you know most of them are chill too
i feel like yeah most people aren't even
worried about it man you know
that's what i feel like a lot of people
are always worried about like oh well i
always used to be worried about like
high school and you'd get high and you'd
be like dude
you're looking over your shoulder like
who's out to get me like all the time
and it's just like you're sparing it's
like it was no one really
i don't know i was just always i was
just i just saw weemos when i was a kid
so oh for sure it was a different
experience oh yeah
it is different in the gang town
it's scary um damn
hold on real quick i know you can cut
this what's that noise
no that it's the cricket
i think it's a cricket
yeah it's loud
that's a loud-ass cricket yo he's got to
be in here
it's coming from outside even yo what is
happening so i'm sure those dabs are
amplifying that [ __ ]
it's just i i thought it was i had to
stop
i know you can clip this out it's louder
than the rain was
yo what is that gonna [ __ ] up this video
oh crap a [ __ ]
one cricket i just had to make sure
i just had to make sure that it's insane
it's a loud cricket you know what
okay beep
[Laughter]
you know i was tripping i'm sorry i
thought that was me
you didn't say anything so i'm like yo
am i the one who should have been like
we don't hear
oh yeah all right ready go all right so
so you're fresh out here a weekend what
are your plans
it's just me the main thing it was uh
that i've been doing is like meeting as
many people as possible like my goal has
been like
just meet one person like whether it's
like industry or like party person or
like whoever the [ __ ] like friend or
like whatever like a person a day like
get one number a day and that's been the
truth so far like i've just met like
hello people and that's been like just
in like networking like meet people like
that's really what that's okay you know
a cool goal i got to be honest
yeah that's pretty well i've never heard
anything like that before
yeah i'm just trying to meet like
literally as many people as possible
like now when i get my [ __ ] out there
like
i've met some like pretty cool people in
like some crazy industries just from
like a week of being here like some
crazy photographer that does some cool
[ __ ] and like
a couple of weed industry people that
like never would have been close to
meeting in texas you know like
you have to make the move it's the same
thing i did you had to make the move man
yeah it's crazy
like it's crazy to see the difference
how immediate it was and i was like
all your friends are gone now though if
they're back in texas yeah
yeah i have a couple of friends out here
in la and um actually you're a little
you're like your home oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's right
yeah that was a rough part [ __ ] it's
good though man good chance it's the
best thing for you
yeah it's the best thing you could have
did yes thank you thank you [ __ ] yeah
i'm stoked for you thank you bro i'm
super hyped about it
um sorry damn i know we had to make a
bleep but then that qriket threw me the
[ __ ] up i had a whole
subject in my head and now it's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hold on all right we're good um
so uh let's pick it up we're
you're you're making videos weed weed
videos 18
you start gaining a following you start
making money off of it
right then you start transitioning to
that to the um
brand here you are right
yeah so everybody right there they got
distracted by that [ __ ] qriket
too we're caught back up okay
there it is get sidetracked sometimes my
bad i'm surprised i haven't been ranting
let me just stop everybody 25 [ __ ]
minutes in and
there's no ranting yet i haven't [ __ ]
done until now
i guess talking about it so dude
let me ask you a question for everyone i
know this is
these are questions that these are fan
questions that has to be
because these are not questions i would
normally ask but they're i know their
questions are people
you shouldn't know you should ask this
you ever got too [ __ ] high and just
passed out done throw up have you ever
greened out horribly
yes uh the liquid karma video
so i i drank the whole bottle for a
liquid karma video like an idiot
thousand milligrams
and like down like 160 pounds and it was
like probably my first time doing over
like
400 and i was like [ __ ] i'm gonna go
hard for the video the video turned out
okay like i was doing well
30 minutes after i start editing it i
was like going hard this day i was like
[ __ ] it let's get this video out
start editing 30 minutes after you got
done filming yeah dude
it was like high as [ __ ] and then i
started to notice the screen a little
bit and it started to like move a little
bit like almost like i was [ __ ]
tripping
and i was like wait and i started to get
a little like nauseous and dizzy i was
like ah nah i gotta lay down like [ __ ]
now
so i laid down and then i got the spins
like you would when you're just like
black out drunk and i tried to like
sleep
and my head would just spin and i was
like nah i'm gonna vomit and it was like
the probably the hardest i've ever
thrown up in my entire life
like projectile vomit like
like i had to like make that noise and
it was like like a waterfall and it was
like
i didn't feel better after i didn't feel
better after at all passed out though oh
yeah for sure after that
like yeah like yeah it [ __ ]
damn dude one time i accidentally ate
way too much rso
and at once i took the wrong dosage
exactly what happened i got the spins
tried to close my eyes but kept spinning
so bad threw up
passed out but felt horrible never felt
better after i puked
oh really yeah that's usually how i feel
so when you say i'm like oh that's a
i feel what you're saying yeah
definitely crazy stuff bro we did some
crazy stuff to you
yeah too much um the only time i've ever
gotten
close to just throwing the [ __ ] up is
off the pins when i do those
killing all the grandparents oh bro you
know [ __ ] come on
jesus dude almost puke it's
like it's like there's just the too high
yeah you feel higher you're like
oh you know those times in high school
you get in your dreams like i'm gonna
throw up
just just praying and that's how i feel
like
put your head on the cold that's how i
feel
like that like you said like you drink
too much damn did i just relive that
whole feeling i was disgusting
depends man dude projectile throw up
vomit off of liquid karma
yeah damn i never tried it before it's
pretty dope i'll get you a little bottle
[ __ ] diet i'm saying yeah for sure
i'm saying if you're throwing up
like it's probably sugary though too it
is in the sugar it's like actual syrup
it's like if you mix in a drink it's
nice but like you can like it's like you
fill it in the cap full and it tastes
pretty good like everyone i give it to
they're like oh it tastes good
my girlfriend passed out off of it
actually this is
a crazy starter should probably tell
this i'm gonna tell it
okay so we actually go to six flags
which is uh
six flags in texas in san antonio yeah
it's pretty fresh actually it's got some
rides yeah it's called
yes the texas baby so uh we go there
we're in like line for this like brand
new ride or whatever and she
drank i think three capfuls so it's like
150 milligrams
so i guess she didn't expect it to be
that much because she really doesn't
take more than like 50 you know most
people don't really take me
in like 50 or like honestly 10. it's 20
yeah it hits them though yeah for sure
yeah so we're just in line she's like
you know i mean she has her arm over me
and then she's just like i think i'm
gonna green out and i was like
i said what she said those words yeah
she's like i think i'm gonna green i was
like huh
and then like she's just like i look at
her and then her knees just like buckle
and then she just like imagine like a
pancake like folding like she got
knocked the [ __ ] out it looks like
i thought someone said her cats are
sleeping
it looked like she was like like
literally she just fell and i was like
oh my god
and the worst part i guess was i tried
to grab her like i
almost caught her like one of her arms
so i can imagine like you're falling and
then one of the arms so your head goes
like
and then she knocked her head on the
ground and i was like
what just happened hold on this is in
line yes
see i knew i knew you would know i knew
you were gonna know
exactly what happened it was the joker
so like immediately everyone should like
oh my god like there's like a little
yeah
like oh [ __ ] like i just need someone to
get me some [ __ ] water like something
and like there's a little
medical team that they come in and
they're like did you tell you guys
no for sure not nurse like hot i was
like it's really hot and i was like i
think she just you know needed some
water you know it's really hot inside
and they're like yeah
they're like for sure and i think they
could tell i was high [ __ ] because i was
also like i drank like probably two or
three times to her
so i was like this can't happen right
now like in the middle of that i was
just like so
[ __ ] fake that i was like no
yeah some [ __ ] crazy stuff so
question
did you guys recover and keep riding
rides no
i know i wanted to i was literally yeah
no it was almost the end of the day but
i was like
number the end of your day that was it
yeah it was like begging to go under i
was like just go on one right she was
like
oh you just passed yeah i was like dude
i was like i did not just wait in line
to just watch you pass out i was like i
need to ride
one ride for sure that was our first
ride we didn't run a segal one
all night paid for admission which is
like 60 [ __ ] dollars the first ride
the first ride didn't ride a single ride
the whole [ __ ] night
insane i was like i have to ride one bro
that's awful you should have pulled a
dick moving right when she passed down
like help her
and then take off in front of the line
yeah everyone was like just like spaced
out and i just snagged that
yo um i'm sorry i'm i i didn't mean to
say that i don't know your girlfriend
i'm sorry
it was just a joke it was a joke
damn dude all right sorry that's a
that's a great sitcom right there
yeah for sure i love i love scenes like
that wouldn't be like i think the same
thing when i'm like dude that could be a
[ __ ] show like what just happened
could just be a script and everyone yeah
is seinfeld do you watch seinfeld yeah
watch a few seasons of it for sure
so if you have seinfeld moments in your
life
you know you've had them but this is
unbelievable i can't believe everything
is [ __ ] here yeah it was recording
like [ __ ] impossible
dude have you ever had a see i have to
i'm asking from a perspective of
i know these are questions people are
going to love to hear yeah so i have to
hear because i'm always [ __ ]
telling stories and [ __ ]
and it's cool to ask somebody that doing
the same [ __ ] basically i do
like the same exact lane it's [ __ ]
awesome to hear the stories of somebody
else doing this [ __ ] yeah it's cool as
[ __ ] oh yeah
um what was your first time buying weed
by yourself like not with your friends
nothing
you know that experience of you going by
yourself feeling like
i'm growing up now [ __ ] about myself
going about weed you know what i'm
saying like
not with the homies what was the
experience can you remember or did it
become such a habit at that point you
were just like oh let me pick up the
sack real quick by myself
like that because at the first when i
was first smoking like i kind of made it
a thing like it was just like my [ __ ]
youthful mind i was like trying to keep
my grades intact and stuff i was like
i'm only gonna smoke when i'm with
homies like on the weekends so that was
like the first few months and it was
senior year
was the first time i smoked by myself oh
[ __ ] yeah so it was like a year and a
half for almost like two years of
smoking weed
just like just with homies yeah damn
nearest balls that sounds amazing
yeah it was pretty it was a pretty nice
time for sure but
i almost wish i smoked more because it
was just like [ __ ] it was just high
school
like you know it was like if you if
that's the way you did it and that's the
way it had to be
right that's awesome that's the first
time i think i've ever heard anybody say
that [ __ ]
except for my one friend that's an
actual psychologist now
because he did they like nope we're
doing a homework he would always be
doing his homework while we're getting
high
and then he'd smoke or you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] because by the time monday came
none of us had our homework done but his
ass yeah yeah he's getting paid
there you go yeah by uh so you know here
though that all went away and i was just
getting high all the time for sure
really but i almost can't remember the
first time i do remember
i mean you went to college you have do
you have good grades yeah i had
i had pretty decent grades in college
enough to like yeah i'm down for another
one for sure
thank you uh good enough grades in
college to like definitely pass the
classes but
not enough to like get on the honorable
stuff and i lost scholarships and stuff
because like you needed like a 4.0 or
like
even like a three like a [ __ ] three
five and [ __ ] and i just didn't have
that so
that was right yeah yeah uh utsa
it's a university in san antonio yeah
university of texas
another like a couple other schools that
like my homies are going to and stuff
like there's texas tech and like texas a
m which like party schools would have
been super fun
but uh that was the only school that
gave me a full ride like for like oh
like all my [ __ ] was paid for so i was
just like how can i like
scholarship right and then you're saying
you didn't get enough good grades so
they took your scholarships away yeah so
i got like not one full ride but it was
like multiple scholarships that were all
just like combined
to cover the tuition and then by the
time it was like and like second
semester sophomore year i lost like
25 percent of it in the end in like
junior year i lost like
it was like kids 10 to 5 so like and
this is why you're doing videos and all
this shit's happening
yeah exactly and i'm just like this is
[ __ ] up
and then they got to a point where it
was like just recently it was like
it caused a lot like an insane amount of
stress like college is [ __ ] stressful
especially they get like full amount of
classes i was taking like five classes
and uh trying to do this full-time and
like a whole bunch of other stuff and i
have the visions of like moving to la
and like starting the brand and
everything i was like dude i have too
much on my plate right now so i was like
i have to drop one thing and it's like
college is always going to be there
and it'll probably be [ __ ] free who
knows maybe joe biden will make it free
and interesting
let's go back to that [ __ ] then we'll be
all right so like we'll be all right so
it's like my whole thing was like i
don't feel like i'm going to
need it on a resume like i want to build
an experienced resume that's like
i already got what i need to do from
college like i'm not going to say was
useless i definitely advise people to go
to college i learned a [ __ ] out in
college for sure especially about
marketing which is my degree and like
what's going to help me in the brand and
everything like
i would definitely recommend it if you
can get some [ __ ] paid for you know what
i mean if you have like
maybe if you don't know what you're
doing like i would almost
i don't know it's [ __ ] expensive
that's true
it's [ __ ] expensive bro it doesn't
even make sense was that if you need
your hand held through it it takes a lot
of discipline to like
do it online you can get a lot of those
type of stuff which is great online
courses and [ __ ] yeah 100
most people need their hand held through
it that's me
oh [ __ ] that guy did now he's driving a
train it's our built-in sound effect
yo you should you should start adding
some [ __ ] around that
so how long did you go to school for
three and a half was in my last semester
and i was just like nah i'm not gonna do
this
that's time to hear him me yeah
i only have one class until i get my
degree yeah
i was in my last [ __ ] semester i went
i don't
[ __ ] care anymore literally the same
i was like that's
a hundred percent exactly the same
that's exactly
what happened to me yeah we gotta do a
series of you guys going back and check
that's amazing when did you stop was
this recent you stopped
bro this past semester like i'm supposed
to this is a fresh
fresh this is like a few like i stopped
going to class pretty much like i'm just
like i'm not going to sign up for a
different right like yeah it's just
completely like
and i could immediately tell like i was
just getting to a point where i was like
super stressed and super anxious and it
was like actually weighing on my mental
because i didn't really deal with any of
those problems like maybe it was the
weed or like
growing up i never really dealt with
that but like this is the first time
where i would like wake up and just like
feel [ __ ] weird like i need to like
throw up i was like i have so much [ __ ]
to do
so stressed so anxious and it's like i
need to drop something for sure like
just to keep my like
mental intact you know what i mean so i
was like school will always be there
[ __ ] it
like i'll see you later that's reason
yeah don't don't feel bad because i know
when you did you're like [ __ ] it was a
big decision it's a big decision yeah
100
huge it's your whole [ __ ] life till
that point 100
and especially telling people like mom
mom respected it my mom acted in the
same way that she did when she found
that i did these like we do
youtube videos who people my mom no what
did you say and especially
what did you say especially what people
i didn't oh the people when i made the
video
like they're always like uh i thought
you said italian people oh no
especially like italian people they were
watching my video go oh
so that's why i had to keep i was like
wait a minute
i didn't need to get deep in that story
like where's this was that what is he
talking about
my bad no i thought you said yeah but
like all the people
comments dms and they'll be like bro you
just like need to finish and i was like
dude
trust me like i'm good like i couldn't i
couldn't finish it like it was like
nah i was probably gonna fail that [ __ ]
and i was like just not there mentally
like in the last few classes i didn't
even need like
i felt like i got everything i needed to
from college like i learned what i
needed to do for sure
damn that's a big decision that's good
though if that's what you felt you
needed to do then do it that's exactly
you're doing
you literally said exactly what happened
to me i went to school and then never
finished
just like [ __ ] i don't even lose yeah
so
so close i mean you did a four-year
college that's different you have you
you didn't do bad
and say that you're finishing on track
all right you do bad never feel bad
about that because i finished school
like that i felt so
shitty for months but i also
i know you guys have heard this forever
you probably haven't i went to a jc
but for five years okay yeah because i
never refuse
no i win every semester i was just so
weird i'm like you know what i'm gonna
leave class let me know
and i'd be out and then they dropped me
because i would do it so much
and i go [ __ ] okay next semester next
semester next week i would do
school for two and a half months and
leave two and a half definitely
it's a long [ __ ] the semester isn't
long dude i'm so let's just
i [ __ ] up so many times so yeah you're
on you're doing way better than i
[ __ ] did
trust me damn dude that's a big decision
so you left
um and you're out and your family are
they pissed
uh they're not pissed they're just like
they understand understand what i'm
doing right now like it was like i said
the same thing about like the we
tube it was like it wasn't like what are
you doing it was like okay i understand
because you're like making something of
it like it's not just
i thought they were going to see it as
i'm just smoking weed on the internet
but they kind of see like what i have
behind it like the vision like i'd
explain to them like what it's going to
be
and like because i think weed is just
like drug like dare program [ __ ] you
know what i mean that's how my
grandparents parents are for sure
and it took a while to convince them
that it wasn't that and it was just like
dude it's gonna be like tobacco's gonna
be like beer like imagine getting into
these industries like 100 200 300 years
ago like come on
and that's how they like that's how i
explained it to him and that's how they
finally understood like okay like he's
not like
stupid about it you know i mean i think
the main thing they thought i was like
just stupid
but at the same time you're in school
and [ __ ] and it's something you're
truly talking about like yeah they can't
be mad at i'm glad to hear that man
that's like a very rare answer it's
99 yeah they're [ __ ] pissed
but that's that's great to hear at least
you got some support that's awesome man
because i know exactly what you're
talking about like
i have so much to do i've been through
that [ __ ] for years
yeah that's it sucks yeah dude it weighs
on everything you feel
[ __ ] tired you feel like you can't
sleep but you're tired like it's like a
whole draining and then it's almost
yeah like you said i feel anxious like i
have 90 things to do where do i start
[ __ ] this guy's not ready so i can only
do half of these things
and then i can only do an email on these
things and wait two weeks
yes right you gotta like time it all up
and then like sometimes you miss time
things and it's like ah throws this
thing off and if you're going yeah and
especially if you're going to school
already
and this is i'm only talking about what
we're doing like for the weed and the
business and the advertising
taking on doing brands and making your
own brand that is what i'm talking about
and you have a full-time [ __ ] school
schedule on the side
yeah you're killing it yeah i was just
like nah it was like i was killing it
for a little bit and then it just starts
to like
but now it's a real thing i guess
especially with school bro it's just
like [ __ ] you up
gets hired quick yeah for sure man
you're going full-time school too that's
amazing i did not know
i didn't know you were going to school
like that that's [ __ ] awesome
wow yeah uh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
like you said it'll always be that it
might be free when you go back 11 years
what i'm thinking and it's like
i mean god forbid i do need the degree
and like everything just like falls as
[ __ ] and i'm like whatever homelessness
whatever i'll get a degree
i'll get that [ __ ] degree for free
we'll see yo so do you have to pay for
everything
since you haven't finished uh
[ __ ] maybe did you just bring that up
is that when you started thinking about
like wait do i
i don't you have to pay back your [ __ ]
yeah you gotta pay that [ __ ] back
right i'm still paying that [ __ ] back
are you
yeah yeah no i mean no matter if you
take the class they make you pay that
[ __ ] back
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] thank god it's not an
expensive school i guess
it's an in-state school it's not private
or anything but [ __ ] no way i mean a lot
of it was grants
oh that's right you did say that you did
say that you said that i'm burnt
yeah you'll be fine you might you might
be right there i [ __ ] hope i'm not
yeah i don't know i hope you're not too
i'm scared for [ __ ]
either way everybody gonna buy some [ __ ]
they're excited
all right man that's [ __ ] running
this tuition oh just gotta
just found out i had a whole nother
just hit me when i came to the i was i
was filming with thomas
oh it was the worst uh moment of my life
until today
um my bad yo clackamas man
i i i owe clackamas community college
from oregon
money apparently hey i never even went
to your school all right
[ __ ] you guys this is on camera on tape
[ __ ] you guys all right
they didn't do [ __ ] they keep trying to
charge me for classes i never went to
because i used to go there in high
school [ __ ] that [ __ ]
oh that's crazy you know like on the day
you have to get them or something no you
don't have to pick your days
and you pick your colleges like who do
you think you're going to go to well
obviously you know what you're talking
about
you have to pick the i picked the
[ __ ] schools and now they're charging
me
[ __ ] out of here anyway
off of tuition talk that's a different
show
here we go so in all the years that
you've been doing this
you're in texas and you're coming to
california has anybody ever recognized
you and blew your [ __ ] cover while
you're in texas
uh not blew my cover oh one time i got
posted a picture i just got recognized a
lot so i would have to explain like
oh i'm just like you know i'm just
visiting for a little bit because my
family lived there so like i'm just
visiting my family and most of them knew
that they were like okay
but i remember there's just one spot
near the campus that i would just chill
and drink out a lot and i saw the same
guy like
[ __ ] every weekend he'd be like wait
a minute like why are you here every
weekend
and i was like ah bruh i just live here
like you put on a low key so no one ever
like spread it or anything you know i
mean i'm sure some people knew but
i think there was one picture that
someone tagged me in and it was on
twitter
it was like at the bar he like tagged
the location and like in his bio he was
like
blank and like utsa and he had like all
his [ __ ] and i was like brad
like that blew your [ __ ] up like that
yeah that's the worst man it was [ __ ]
but
we're all good no i'm not you're right
yeah now i'm out of there baby
i live in tokyo tokyo man what are you
talking about
downtown yeah just out of there
i live in l.a county that's you could
say now la county somewhere
somewhere very vague big little
metropolis
yeah do you have to have fun i'm so
[ __ ] hyped right now thinking that
you just moved here
how crash out here dude i'm so excited
it's a [ __ ] good time like i'm just
i'm just loving it for sure nice man so
just i just
love hearing like you just got your
[ __ ] car he moved out
here you're doing oh man i'm cool
thank goodness yeah cool i'm sorry very
cool that's
it it's a good feeling i mean right when
i moved out here that first week i was
like
what the [ __ ] yeah
when i bring homies out here and [ __ ]
they're like bro i didn't know it was so
unlike gta and i'm like it's
the same thing yeah we're having this
conversation driving to get weed me and
marty today yeah
yeah my old apartment buildings and gta
the ones i lived in
no [ __ ] that's downtown so i was looking
like this is [ __ ] insane
that's awesome damn they've been a while
since gta 6 huh they'll be sick i wonder
where it's going to be
was that insider info you had on that
[ __ ] earlier
whoa just spill it man you got it no
we've talked about it many times
oh have we talked about on the podcast
about about you've never talked about
yo what's up dj poo donny come on man
come on i know we haven't talked in a
long time but
we should do so dj pool's the guy that
wrote uh
the guy that wrote friday right he
writes the gta scripts too
right oh [ __ ] and he's a red from gta
from friday that gets punched in the
face yeah that's dj pooh he's a director
i know those guys i know him and the guy
named donny donnie anderson what's up
he's cool as [ __ ] he's a wild
[ __ ] i have a story about him i
don't know if i can i'm allowed to say
it's really awesome but i'll just keep
it like that until i talk to him
the way i met this man was so [ __ ]
amazing [ __ ] i can't even talk about it
never mind anyway they write gta and a
couple years ago
i was talking to them and they told me
i'm like [ __ ]
and then they were like you know you are
dj poo you're probably not bullshitting
me never mind i was like my bad all
right you guys right gta keep going
and i was like i don't believe you guys
and i asked what's up pumpkin gta so
they like agreed so for like four years
straight i'm like
i'm just waiting for them to let me know
when gta 6 starts because they're like
yeah we'll put you in part six i'm like
yo
just can i not just get shot please
don't let me get shot in the scene
because if somebody doesn't like me
online that's it it's gonna be a meme
and a gift i mean it's getting popped
in [ __ ] gta in the script over and
over and over and over again
i was like yo just let me be like the
guy that introduced you to the wii farm
or something
that was i asked so amazing amazing
right so when you talk about gta i was
going
oh [ __ ] because gta is already getting
made and i never got a call
damn it they never called me so it's a
bittersweet moment because it's my
favorite game of all time
yeah grand theft auto yeah in the hand
that's [ __ ] it's so
sad it makes me so sad it's like
immortalize me guys put me in the game
forever please
that's amazing yo come on man i can be
happy for the rest of my life go
you like gta i'm [ __ ] up
so tight damn it hey dj boom donny let
me know
um on to other things before i get all
sad and [ __ ]
i'm just waiting for eight years
basically for that [ __ ] to happen
um okay on to other things yes so you're
out here you're fresh out here let's get
on to another [ __ ] topic
because i'm about to start rambling all
right i'm getting high
i'm chilling damn we're already 50
minutes in [ __ ]
wow how long do you usually go depends i
don't know
i don't know we'll see we'll just see
yeah it depends dude we've done like
three hours the one we did
it was four hours uh it's just going
yeah
sometimes it'll be an hour do you edit
them or really just let it like free
throw or like
marty marty edits them uh
all the edits remember like when i
because you you've been on youtube like
since what 16 17-ish yeah right around
there yeah i started making
or that's when the weed tube started i
started making gameplay videos like 2014
i want to say
gotcha gotcha because like 2018 the end
of 2018 is when i was like you know what
i'm starting to do youtube because i had
to youtube for four years never [ __ ]
did anything with i just made the name
you know right yeah yeah just had the
[ __ ] so whenever when i saw you because
i was looking up like who does youtube
are there different youtubers than
instagrammers because i never
yeah just like delving in it's like a
whole world it's a whole that's what i
wasn't
getting too holy [ __ ] there's people and
then i saw it like
when a youtuber can have a hundred
thousand followers or subscribers
and on instagram they'll have a million
because it like it transfers over
so weirdly it's so odd how it transfers
like that so i thought
it's strong youtube is real that's a
hundred thousand
real [ __ ] subscribers then real
people watching
i didn't know how powerful youtube was
at all ever it's the second biggest
website in the world what's the first
google oh just like damn
they own [ __ ] well i thought you went
on twitter
what the [ __ ] is he talking about i
don't know nothing about this
cryptocurrency
i don't even know none of the references
you're making like yo what the [ __ ]
the only ones i get i'm like yo i know
about
saints i don't know about the same thing
baby i am not on this crypto [ __ ] yo
please
please so me and marty don't have
[ __ ] breakdowns can you explain
cryptocurrency to me in a dumb guy
version like look at me like i have no i
do
i have no [ __ ] clue how this [ __ ]
works how is it nothing more than me
going
you know inside this lighter you could
put it in the computer there's
50 billion dollars on it i mean
but don't lose it don't forget the
password yeah
how is it how is it not just that and
then going hey by the way
we shut the company off none of you guys
have money how what protects me
how is this how do why do people want
this i'm so ignorant man
i have no idea and i know you know it
yeah please break it down to me why it's
valuable
uh there's a couple different crypt it's
a main way people say bitcoin is a way
to just like
a store of value it's just like a
protection against inflation
if something were to go down like if the
dollar were to go to [ __ ]
bitcoin is still going to be worth the
amount it's worth and if not
it's going to take a lot more money to
buy that bitcoin because of inflation so
it's just going to be it's always going
to like hold its value and people are
always going to assume that it holds
value or at least that's what
really keeps it valuable is really
people assuming holds value yeah
which is why anything holds value though
oh yeah like the dollar yeah
it's like but i i think it gets me it's
not tangible i can't touch
any of my money like how do i know i
have that money it scares me
yeah but that's like i mean a lot of
people said that about like mayo for a
while
or like yeah a lot of people said that
about a whole thing's like how would i
like how would i ever not hold my mail
or like something like that but a lot of
people have bank accounts a lot of
people have like credit cards like you
can't see the money behind a credit card
lately right no i'm just saying like
what are you talking about my [ __ ]
debit card yeah
you just like it's a number on a screen
just because it's a place of a bank i'd
trust it more but then at a
cryptocurrency bank i would trust it too
right yeah and cryptocurrency the whole
thing is that there is in a bank
there is no bank like it's a whole thing
it's like it's decentralized the
government can't touch it like it's
completely separate entity from
i'm sorry how do you get your money out
if you want tangible money like you want
cash to go buy a car
and the guy's a [ __ ] hick and he's
like no i don't take [ __ ] credit
cards
and he's like i need cash how do you get
your money out
well then you just gotta i guess it's
just in the way of the future
like that's just like a way of the past
i guess they're thinking like bitcoin's
gonna be or like
cryptocurrency in general is a way that
it's not like
physical like it's past that type [ __ ]
you know like it's the way email was
like we're not even gonna ship
like postcards or like stamps like put
that whole thing out of business like
we're just gonna completely digitally
send your mail and cryptocurrencies like
we're gonna completely
digitize your money so you don't have to
hold it and it's there's different
cryptocurrencies that are a lot better
for
transferring money to one another like
some cryptocurrencies are just like slow
at doing it like
a lot of people admit that like it's not
completely where it needs to be but it's
like very early into like what it can be
then like it's going to be like in 10 20
years we're going to be thinking like
where the [ __ ] is that dollar bill like
you know what it means like that's like
kind of the hope yeah
but so there's no there is no way to get
your money out though
to to make it physical i mean there's
bitcoin machines which is strange i've
never used one but if you go to gas
stations like bitcoin machines like buy
bitcoin and like transfer your bitcoin
or whatever but
it's really just you can sell your
bitcoin you know for like
cash and then that money you can go and
transfer into your bank account
oh no [ __ ] yeah so like you buy
cryptocurrency on things called
exchanges which is like
there are different places that actually
hold bitcoin and you buy it and then you
hold it and then like you can just
sell it for i guess whatever you have
there's places that accept bitcoin you
can send
bitcoin to another address you can just
uh they're called wallets so each person
has a wallet so i could send my bitcoin
to your wallet
like venmo [ __ ] right and the whole
thing is like it's supposed to be
instant and it's supposed to be
non-traceable that's the whole thing the
way bitcoin started it's like
super black everybody wants to sell some
drugs basically
yeah that's what a lot of people think
it is because that's really how it
started became popular it was like a
really
safe way to buy and sell [ __ ] on the
black market it was like super just
non-traceable like even if the feds knew
you were buying and selling [ __ ] like
they couldn't even see it
they couldn't even track it or prove it
or anything like that like it's
completely separate
from like the government and the feds
and like the systems like it's
decentralized you know it's like there's
no
central place where it like see that's
so odd to me because it's it's it's more
than like yo if i lose this little chip
that puts like i'm broke it's isn't that
scary though
there's no bank you can't keep it at
yeah i mean
a little bit right yeah because you
could essentially lose your life if
someone steps on your ship or something
yeah there's cases of that people
have like 30 bitcoin like when they
bought it a whole
bunch of years ago and they can't get
into the account this guy has like
i think it's like a few i want to say
it's almost a few million dollars worth
of bitcoin and he doesn't know the
password
and if you have more than 10 password
accounts it completely like deletes your
account and he's on his ninth attempt
he's on his ninth attempt and he doesn't
know the password so he's about to lose
like a few million dollars and he's just
like
that's not fair yeah it's [ __ ] so it
is like
it's it's really early i feel like like
we're just talking about it in its baby
infant stages so
there'll be like fixes and better ways
to buy it and like
because that's the main thing holding it
back in my opinion like having
to like tell like every single person
this you know what i mean like every
single person wants to know what
cryptocurrency is but it's such a
lengthy explanation like it needs to get
to a point where it's like oh it's just
digital money you know what i mean like
people understand it instantly so it
needs to be
a lot more accessible to everybody
because you're like i don't even like
most people don't even know how to buy
it you know you have to buy it on
certain exchanges have to like get an
app like create an account and like
transfer your money and it's like it's a
lot of [ __ ] you know it needs to be just
like
boom bye because you already don't
understand real money
most the average person's like yeah true
you just get a dollar bill and you
assume it's worth a dollar and you trade
it for like this and you're like okay
that's
nice so you trade one bitcoin i guess
right now for like fifty three thousand
dollars you can trade one 53
yeah one bitcoin is like fifty three
thousand dollars i think it was like i
mean it's right
you buy that train with that budget and
they can't figure out how to do a
goddamn
password recovery i guess it's that's
unreal dude
yeah it's 53 000 for bitcoin my homie
was buying it when it was like
16 or 13 000. exactly but you're saying
you get a physical
chip are you saying that right no it's
like a usb right
you could prefer that you can get how do
you hold your big how do you log into
your bitcoins like a card or something
it's uh you can have there's like
different paths one's called like a
passphrase like different exchanges will
have different things
um you'll have a physical password that
you're supposed to write down and never
lose like just in case
yeah and then you'll have the one that
you create whatever one you want
and then there's like two-factor like
three-factor authentication and a whole
lot of [ __ ] to get into it so like it's
really secure like to get into it
but you have like two passwords i
thought it was like on a card like on
some villains [ __ ]
my bad this whole time that's why i was
saying what are some steps on your [ __ ]
are you
done no i don't know the little thing is
it's not physical like you don't hold it
like it's not
it was something you had to hold my plug
in look how much [ __ ] money is on my
chip
no it's like you just pull it up i guess
on your phone or like poke whatever like
just like you would a bank account you
know it's just like numbers on the
screen at the end of the day i'm
so very real this whole time i thought
you had okay
do dispensaries take bitcoin right now
or is that whoa
maybe in the future that's so if one
bitcoin is worth fifty three thousand
dollars
how do you go buy an eighth at the shop
you can
divide bitcoin you can divide bitcoin
into like point zero zero zeros or like
however like
there's like i don't even know how many
denominations you can put but like it's
like one or something like that
ten dollars this is [ __ ] crazy yeah
so you can send someone like point zero
zero zero zero zero one
point yeah and it'll be like there are
so many people like me sixty dollars
right now
people will say like oh i own half a
bitcoin i'll be like damn okay you got
30 you got 30 racks on you yeah how does
it start
how do you get your first bitcoin
without trading cash for it or do you
just buy it with cash
uh you can i guess buy it with cash if
you have like a bank account but i guess
you need a bank account first a lot of
these exchanges will
convert your money into bitcoin and then
give bitcoin into your account and then
you have that bitcoin
i thought it might be some members only
[ __ ] somebody's got to give you a little
piece now you're in
oh no you can anyone can buy bitcoin or
any cryptocurrency at any time
i'm so bad that should just confuse me
so hard the real future is nfts if you
wanted to get in some [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] what did i say the other day
my friends i was i haven't hung out with
people in a long time something [ __ ]
it's been a virus in and [ __ ] future
bro i could talk about those so that's
what i'm saying i was in the [ __ ]
room for the first time with a lot of
people
but my homies were just sitting there
chilling and someone brings up nft i go
what does that mean
all right thomas this is what you're
gonna need to know like oh [ __ ] this
i'm confused all let me explain what i
think nfts are and then you tell me
all right let's hear it so nft is like
say that meme you know that meme and me
marty that i'm smoking a giant bowl with
a torch
and it's that [ __ ] mean that gets
passed around yeah we posed a good
question about this already right
so that's like saying i own that and if
i wanted to sell
that to somebody that original post like
it's the
block chain something is what we were
trying to figure out is okay you got
that
elon musk smoking the wheat yeah yeah
who owns it is it rogan
or the guy that made the elon or is it
the dude that made
the meme see exactly that's the question
that's what nft's answer
like you will be able to click on it and
say like oh he's the one but who owns it
the one that how do you it's on joe
rogan's show
it's elon musk but who's the guy that
snapshot of the picture made the meme
who gets credit who's allowed to sell it
whoever is the
i mean first one to upload it as an nft
i suppose damn
are you [ __ ] like of those three
people yeah i mean you could
have an official one but the thing is
like can i just take a picture of you
and make an nft and then make money off
you
that's not right you could he said but
i'm saying that if i were to make one
then the whole belief is that like it's
not like authentic like if you were to
just take a picture of me
it hopefully like the belief is that
wouldn't sell as much as if i took like
a picture because it's from me
you know what i mean and you would be
able to prove that it's from me and it's
not just a picture
of me how would we able to prove it from
you though
like that's the whole nft thing like you
can click on it improve ownership just
from like the
very unique hash that it creates so
we're saying before this podcast comes
out monday i have to make an nft
of that picture before somebody else
does because we're talking about it now
that [ __ ] is probably sale if you go on
yeah if you go on openc which is the
main place you buy nfts and you type in
like joe rogan i'm sure there's like
hundreds of
actual pictures of that so maybe it's
oversaturated already you know but it
it'll all just break yeah it'll all just
one of one
exactly it'll it will be a one-of-one
but maybe joe rogan actually does post
it
like a verified profile on that platform
so you know like you could follow
artists when they release
right correct and then people have like
their own marketplaces and their own
[ __ ] that they sell
and stuff like that so it's really cool
for artwork but the main thing that nfts
are going to be cool for is like the
transfer of goods so like i said you can
like
prove intellectual ownership and
everything of a file
so i think in the future it's going to
completely replace like
paperwork and all that nonsense like
signing leases or transferring cars or
like doing all this [ __ ] that's like
stacks of paperwork or all this like
mortgages and all this [ __ ] it's
just going to be oh you want to buy my
house i'm going to give you this nft and
you prove ownership
it's like [ __ ] it's done that's where
it's going
yeah 100 yeah yeah i'm so [ __ ]
you could do that with cryptocurrency
you'd cancel out like anything you need
to do forever
exactly exactly and that's why like
banks are like scared of it like that's
why banks are always talking about like
cryptocurrency is gonna be the future
because they realize like
who's owners of these cryptocurrencies
aren't they essentially the bank
not necessarily there's a finite amount
of cryptocurrency
uh most cryptocurrency like bitcoin
there's a finite amount of it yeah
and then you just buy like a certain
amount of how much is out there
i got that say the guy that created the
program
or however no one knows who made bitcoin
oh really
yeah what if it's bank of america then
[ __ ] that
then everything's fine and if it is
government we don't give a [ __ ] we're
just laughing here please don't get mad
at us
i'm sorry if that's true we're [ __ ]
high who gives a [ __ ] i think there's
like theories about who made it
people know who made like ethereum like
some russian guy i think really
yeah is it fair to say that the idea
though is that it's the user base that
owns it because
like correct you don't have to pay
overdraft fees well then again
you can't can you pay
can you pay your car insurance with
bitcoin that's what
hopefully is going to be the future so
when people it's accepted
right like tesla just like you can buy a
tesla with bitcoin now like that was
like a big thing like people are like oh
[ __ ] like that's crazy
what yeah you can buy a tesla oh they
knew right that's in like the past month
or so
right that was like in the past few
weeks were you guys seeing this [ __ ]
where'd you guys both agree like yep
that was the last one yes sir
where do you see your news where do you
guys get in this news
what do you look at uh look at reddit
and twitter honestly [ __ ] i look at
twitter
i don't know i've read it i don't know i
don't post on writing but it's a
they post some crazy [ __ ] on there just
like it just keeps you updated on some
random [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i ain't trying to do all that
[ __ ] it's just all like words like
links yeah it's not the best user
experience it looks like [ __ ] i can't
do that it looks
so is there a huge disparity in the nfts
between people getting a lot of money
like the top 01 percentile and then the
rest of people like getting to five like
fiverr damn near
uh i'm pretty sure that yeah 100
but that's just like how most things are
you know what i mean but there's
definitely a set amount
of nft creators that are just like super
hyped that have like audiences that are
making like
thousands and thousands of dollars just
off of their illustrations and stuff and
there's
hundreds maybe thousands hundreds of
thousands of people that are trying to
be those people like
if you go on open c there's just open so
yeah open c is like
what the marketplace is the exchange for
all these nfts so
you can search there there's like a
whole bunch of crazy [ __ ] it's obviously
pretty tight
on the internet it's so sick it's much
chopped and youtube compilations would
you say it's mostly like illustrative or
is it like
like a lot of motion graphics and stuff
it's whatever
oh these are just pictures oh it's not
just pictures it can be like motion
graphics it's like there's um there's
something called um
what's beeplecrap i saw this dude he was
doing
all these political things and he just
he had like
nfts i bet you that so why would
somebody want to buy that
it's just the belief that it like why
would someone buy like the original mona
lisa like i don't know it's just like a
classic piece because they wanted to
post that [ __ ]
and when somebody's posted can't they
just screenshot it and take the
what they paid for but you don't own it
you can click it and say oh he's not the
original owner let's click it oh he's
know that if his original owner
the whole uh the nft like you can prove
ownership like i was saying i'm saying
like say somebody on instagram looks at
your posts and goes
blissful's got a random [ __ ] he's not
the owner how do you prove it
do you gotta go like on the whole like
open seat
that's why it needs to be more
accessible i feel like the answer is
blockchain but i don't understand why
yeah you go through the blockchain like
it's all on the million
dollars yes a 69 million i think that's
like every nft or like a collage of all
the things he's made or something but
it's sold for a stupid amount of money
but it's just like why stupid pieces
like art sculptures or art sell for
hundreds of thousands or millions of
dollars like
it's gonna be pretty crazy i think so
this is pretty crazy too there's gonna
be
i've seen it before there's digital
display frames
and it'll just be like they'll just be
empty and you scan it do whatever and
you can upload your nft and then it's
like a physical yeah
that's cool it's cool i [ __ ] with that
you eject it on your wall yeah exactly
or like in the future people are saying
like your hotel room or whatever you
visit would just be empty
and it'll just be like upload whatever
artwork you want
i like that i can see that you guys ever
seen ready player one
yes is that where we're headed yeah man
it's crazy
it's crazy it was a little intense right
now but i can see it being like
it's more user-friendly what yeah it's
imaginary now but
wow i just feel like that not use obtain
not being able to hold something and see
something and touch is so weird like i
bought those are for 32 million dollars
where's it at check this [ __ ] out
yeah it's on your phone yeah yeah i'm
the owner what
see that number has been me like they're
like damn but yeah
it's gonna be like damn like that is you
it's gonna be like all just gonna take
his world star to start posting
nft is a sick and then boom i swear to
god we'll start is the opening to like
the culture right now
it is like when you asked where i got my
news i didn't want to say that
oh it's not nice
here's another cool thing that you can
do with nfts though so let's say that
you wanted to
um have push trees have like ownership
or spread ownership or like get an
investing round or something
you could sell like say five um you
could sell five nfts
and say they represent like five percent
of your company each and just say
however much like you know i mean
whoever buys that nft
for however much you save or however
much worth like [ __ ] histories is
like let's say it's like five million
dollars right
and then you give them five percent and
then now they are like a part-time
involvement
or part-time owner of your company you
get the money legally yeah
with no contract no contracts nft what
if i wrote you own five percent of this
company and they come at me like you own
five percent like
yeah yo five percent of this company but
i see you get any of the profits
well if we ever sell you get five
percent is that what i can do because
that's [ __ ] up
i mean i suppose so but i hopefully in
the nft and like you can have a whole
lot of like data behind the nft and like
a script or a contract
that's all combined with the one nft
right there's that you can have a file
as an nft you could have
data as an nft you could have like like
i said you could transfer ownership and
like houses you could transfer
you could do whatever with nfts because
you can prove ownership that's the
biggest thing
as a graphic artist it's a complete game
changer that gives reason to like
do graphics if you're a commission forum
as a graphics artist too
the the biggest thing for a graphics
artist you make money off of the second
sale
like on the third sale on the fourth set
you always get a percentage
of the nft sale if you're the original
creator what do you mean
because you can prove you can go back
and see and prove who originally owned
it so let's say i
tell you i sell you like a nft five
dollars and then you sell it to him for
ten
i'll get a portion of that ten dollar
sale and then when he sells it i'll get
a portion of that whatever sale
wow so it's a way for artists yes
exactly
so it's a way for artists to just like
it's automatic yes
hmm yeah it's like a car title damn near
but plus the royalties but it's keeping
track of who owned it who created it or
whatever
right exactly and you could just always
i didn't know i didn't realize any of
this
yeah let's go i feel like i'm back in
school right now and i just got so lost
i feel like what well the coolest part
about that
uh the the ownership part that i was
saying if you wanted to sell five
percent and have it represent five
percent if that person wanted to get out
of the company and sell it to somebody
else and say like hey
this steak of push trees is whatever
like five million dollars like here you
can have it now and they buy
buy it for five million then you get
that sale again and then now they're an
owner
whoa that's pretty simple even though it
sounds complex
yeah it's just like you transfer
ownership really easily you can still
get
it's like yo i went and sold you a pound
every sack you
sell you're gonna give me a little bit
of that just a little bit every 10
seconds
you wish right wouldn't that be [ __ ]
awesome i would be owning this warehouse
right now instead of running it
what exactly that's why it's so [ __ ]
sick especially for artists and people
trying to like having problems with like
people stealing their [ __ ] everything
if you put it in weed terms i get it
what about music producers instead of
just selling beats on sound click or
whatever
yeah sound cloud you could have yeah
there's musical files that you could put
as an nft
a lot of people are dropping like do
people do nfts that are only for
a certain term like you get it but you
got it for a year then it's mine again
um i'm not exactly sure
i don't think so i think once you own it
you own it could you imagine fools are
gonna be flexing
hard online
there's nft shoes no cat what does that
mean
they're just shoes that you're like yo
look at these shoes oh you're like
yeah wait the picture is the nft yeah
yeah look at nft
shoes this is like true like when you
were on madden you got like oh i got the
fast feet card
oh i got the golden hands card exactly
yeah i look at my cards online
like when people show your call of duty
guns all gold full
or like trading cards it's like why is
that pokemon card worth three thousand
dollars like you're driven it's like no
it is
like a hundred percent there's only a
few of them in the world yeah yeah
tangible thing right i'm like yeah this
card right here
three bands but i can go yell this thing
on my phone
[ __ ] i'll show you in a minute
it's so crazy i gotta get over that look
at those
what look at those bad boys these
sneakers were made for your digital
closet you can have
a digi this is the world you can own you
can own digital real estate
and it's the future what you can own
there's a place called like decentraland
is what they call it and it's a giant
world and people are just like
building like you own certain parts of
the world and people are building
advertising for themselves they're like
doing this or like
how do other people see it just going in
like this and like the actual like if
they were to go into the world too like
they would see that
vr no it's like a game on your like oh
oh [ __ ] that's like advertising on gta
yeah right it's nuts see like samsung's
into it
samsung and somebody this is [ __ ]
insane is people going back to sims
when i put on that oculus rift i'm like
oh i don't see how people could
have you tried the vr [ __ ] yes dude it's
awesome it's actually awesome
yeah look up uh nft real estate and see
if that's perfect
you're blowing my [ __ ] mind right now
i don't know
like that all people are into it
yeah you just buy a little piece of
digital
digital ownership well then again it's
like somebody like i own part of the
moon i own this star
you want to go on the actual marketplace
i think that would be best oh on openc
o p e n c all one word marty's computer
should start crashing right
from all these you just see bro you'll
see the prices of these in your mind
will be just [ __ ] like what the
hell is going on a lot of people say
it's just like drug money because like
you know you can be a lot of drugs with
bitcoin they're like what the [ __ ] do i
do with all this money it's like i'm
going to buy some art that hopefully
will just increase in value
appreciating value and now you're not a
drug dealer you're an event aren't ar no
open c
s e a open sca
what yeah there it is
the nft market place
golden state warriors and ft so their
people have like their trading cards
can you buy something more than once
like or does it only
originals uh it depends so trading cards
yeah there will be only one of most of
them oh it's like giffy
so that thing is eight cents it is point
zero five of an ethereum
so if you click ethereum yes the dollar
of theirs right
they use ethereum so it's like bitcoin
they just think of it as like bitcoin
so that one's point two so if you wanna
just click on any of them i think it'll
show the actual price
what so point eight aetherium is 2 000
that's two racks right there so then you
buy it and it goes to your open c
profile that you have like a grid of
right
and now you own it what so they're just
charging really expensive
instagram posts but saying yo
i'm the owner of this that is fun people
are bidding too right
people are busy oh it's just one guy
just reselling nevermind but there's
some people that actually bid on this so
this guy's just like
trying to sell this desperately insane
so there's a lot of people like this
like this is a good example of someone
who's making nfts and just trying to
like you know i mean like he has got an
idea
he's trying to make it like that yeah
he's just trying to like see it at a
price that someone's going to buy it at
so maybe it's not really
not going to come at him and get get him
for having that nike
logo i mean maybe they could probably
ask for some of the profits right
that's crazy as [ __ ] because now it's
got me thinking
it's too big the crypto punks are the
craziest ones crypto
they are crypto punks bro these sell for
thousands and
look 86 ethereum is that one right there
for me
that must be like [ __ ] 400 bands yeah
that's like that for that for that
that's a crypto punk right there man
he's a unique character
if you um click on any of them and then
you click on the properties
like right there where your mouse is
it's like only a certain percent only
five percent have that bandana of all
crypto punks
pretty rare this is pretty crazy yeah
yeah
bro the big shades only five percent
have that's that's
adult [ __ ] pokemon cards right here
two five percent you got two five
percent
things right there it's a rare one rich
guy pokemon trading cards
i can't wait until fools were in the
[ __ ] bars trying to pick up girls
like yo you know what
[Laughter]
yo this just blew my mind are you
serious
thank you for the education so i have to
make that before somebody else does guys
i have to i'm a seller for nine thousand
dollars
or [ __ ] man she asked for more i don't
know how much well they have 69 million
dollars never mind
give a million dollars i'll be happy
with that so what about the guy that
took the picture
of me and i want to sell does he get
profit of that or should i if you want
to like arrange something like that yeah
you could arrange something like in the
code of the nft that like photographer
gets like yeah yo marty can you please
learn all this computer [ __ ] with this
nft so we can make some models
bro if you release some nft it'll be
[ __ ] insane i'm [ __ ] slipping
as a graphic artist and computer website
designer if you come out with some nfts
it'll be insane
you come out with dope as you'll nftc
would be like oh [ __ ] what about the uh
the thing we sent out the other day the
free lock screens that people can get of
our background
it should have been an nft would have
made fun of stupidity
right right okay so i could say here's
the link
everybody can have it but you're not the
original owner is there some nfts like
that
all right uh wait which state then i
could trade like yo you can get the link
there you can have it it's original but
you're not the only owner it's one of
five thousand yeah there's some nfts
that are like one of twenty or like he
really doesn't know one of
five thousand but it really goes down
like whatever whoa fools are gonna be
[ __ ]
flexing their phone oh my goodness
you said you already see people doing
that yes bro you just like uh i follow a
guy
on instagram he's like when one of your
pages has like
1.5 million on it it's just like six
nfts like it's just a screenshot of like
six nfts
so if you lose that password you lose
all your nfts also
[Music]
damn near that but it's like a really
secure like that's why you're supposed
to have like a physical one that's why
you're supposed to have like an actual
like digital password and one that never
changes you can have one that changes
but you have one that's called like your
passphrase or something it's like 10
different words or 10 different like
it's as long as something
you're supposed to keep physically like
at all times like just in case
i'm like crazy this is insane
holy [ __ ] this this the world's getting
[ __ ] insane yeah where do you imagine
when
imagine when a billboard just has a
scannable thing and it's like if you
want to buy this like
little nft like this billboard's an nft
like buy it you can put whatever the
[ __ ] you want here wow
oh my god we're getting into the future
fifth element shit's happening
our cars are gonna start [ __ ] flying
dude i
feel it all right thank you for
educating me on that that was
awesome of course appreciate it
cryptocurrency and nfts you're
learning here today on the uh channel
everybody thank you for everybody in the
car that just got put on game
you buy some money yeah some
cryptocurrencies
okay so that's how it works because now
it makes sense to me
i'm just buying a debit card bank
account that i don't use a display my
password there's my bitcoin my wallet
right
right i learned and i remembered good
[ __ ] see me i need school you got the
internet man
what's up guys thank you so much for
watching the podcast today's ad read is
brought to you by us
this is push trees this is our clothing
company if you don't know that
we started in 2013. it's a streetwear
brand
very weed influenced designs it's just
fun [ __ ] all right there's a lot of fun
stuff [ __ ] that i think is funny
designs we've made over the years if you
guys want to check it out it's
pushtrees.com we got
wallets just dropped cool ass two pound
metal ashtray slash weapon
things they're [ __ ] awesome check
them out so guys it's not really an ad
read we just wanna let you guys know
check out pushtrees.com
back to the episode i'm [ __ ] high
you know how hard that was right now you
[ __ ] kidding me piece of [ __ ] cricket
so you started 2016-17 i got on there
like end of 18
and when i got on there there was only
like like i tell marty a lot like
there's
it's hard to watch content
i'm sure you don't follow a shitload of
youtubers right right
it's yes you're 100 right people ask me
my favorite youtuber and i was like bro
i watched like two maybe
maybe like one or two if i have time
because it's not like oh i'm not
supposed to you're not supporting you
know like
thumbs up so do that [ __ ] it's
it's it's it's people like you smoke
weed on the internet it gets
ah [ __ ] how do i put this without being
an [ __ ] it's a job
way more than you think it is and i'm
not trying to sound ungrateful it's
awesome i i love it but it's it's more
than just
it's more than just smoking the weed is
like okay cool we got the way ready cool
all right make sure everything else is
going make sure these are the lights on
is this going as mike's going okay cool
go
and they edit and you know what i mean
like i do my skeleton edits and marty's
the one that edits all our crazy [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] you see that it's like yeah
they're crazy that's him
he does all the wild [ __ ] so when i got
on there there was like
three or four weed tubers and i saw
yours
and that's when i went oh okay they are
still people because i said i focus on
instagram and all that [ __ ] remember
i said yeah
that's how we got off topic [ __ ]
so i didn't realize there was a world
in youtube and when i got on there there
was very few people
so you said you started seeing what you
said you saw custom grow on there and
who else
uh custom grows on there silence hippie
um let's see
there's like crutch 420 there's matthias
and they got deleted yeah all of them
got deleted it was [ __ ] up
yeah it was really they don't do it at
all no more uh there most of them are
still in the game the ones that i just
mentioned are still in the game and
they're so
okay which is cool sounds hippies i know
they're on instagram yeah but i don't
know about youtube because i don't
follow her on instagram
yeah yeah they're going yeah they go uh
they came back on youtube most of them
did and if they didn't they just started
making
i think videos again a couple years
later when like i guess they realized
they wouldn't get deleted again yeah so
a lot of them started back up again
yeah dude so well i i brought it up
earlier
that's why i was saying when i got on
there it was like
you i saw you and a couple other people
and thinking okay there's still this
because you know
it's not like a competition thing it's
like i want to see other people doing
the same [ __ ] that we're doing
right and like maybe like [ __ ] that was
sick all right we're gonna do a next
video like
you're not gonna ever gonna bite your
[ __ ] it's more like
you did a great [ __ ] job on that let
me see if i can do some [ __ ] all right
he did oh [ __ ] yeah that was
yeah it's more like oh [ __ ] it's like
when basketball players are dunking like
[ __ ] right now i gotta think that was
badass you know what i mean
like holy [ __ ] it's like [ __ ] yeah how
much better can it get
you know that's how i feel about that
[ __ ] so when it got on there and i feel
like there's only like
you and there's not a lot of other
people when i first started that are
still doing active youtube
or they got deleted right yeah exactly
see that's what i think that's why my
channel blew up so much because people
were [ __ ] just looking exactly what
you were looking for
damn we [ __ ] i've rambled so hard my
bad rant i don't even know how i got off
topic
so that's such a cool little [ __ ]
thing though when it got when you're
still there
right you said you made it through the
deletions yeah maybe because you're not
like
showing crazy weed packs yeah that's why
yeah
i think that's why as well and it was
like more of like maybe like half the
video was smoking but a lot of other was
like
vlogging or like posting some other [ __ ]
like jokes with the homies or like you
know what i mean it wasn't just like
too explicit to where it's like he's
funny here's me taking a three grand dab
and throwing up yes
i've done before so don't understand i
love that [ __ ]
i'm saying that's probably why you made
it through right there was a time where
i almost got deleted though and it was
because
uh i had some intro clips and i would
have people submit videos to me of them
just smoke and weed
and it was like submitted by in this
little corner so it like you know give
some recognition to the fan it was
awesome
but uh youtube was like yeah you got to
stop like promoting it it was because uh
there's like some questionably young
people definitely hitting me up and it
would be like yeah and i remember
the coolest one lowkey was like this guy
smoking in a gamestop he just lit up a
fat bloody game stuff
i was like nice i gotta put that
yeah like you're basically encouraging
people yeah exactly yeah they hit you up
youtube
no i was trying to cause i got two
videos deleted and had to like delete
all my videos delete every single video
i had like 100 videos 140 videos
you deleted your videos i had to delete
every single one i was on a trip in
colorado
and i had no internet and i had to
delete eight videos at a time
and it was just page wait i'll delete it
i'll delete it because if i got the
third strike my whole
oh so you would have no videos to strike
left
right and i couldn't private listen to
them yeah i couldn't pry with them
because uh
you at that time if you had a private
video they would still delete it about
unlisted
i don't know but i don't think i mean i
would imagine that like unless they're
private they would still take your [ __ ]
down because like no one could see it
though but it was [ __ ] you
deleted it i had a hell of videos dude
and i just had never uploaded them again
no i have most of them i have most of
them but there's some that are lost to
the void like gone forever it's pretty
[ __ ] up
it's pretty [ __ ] up dude but yeah i
was literally on a trip in colorado and
i was like having the time in my life
and the second video got deleted and i
was like dude like at the time when i
heard about all the people getting
deleted
yeah the second and third would just be
like right away like it would just
happen in the span in like 10 minutes so
i was like dude i just got my second
strike
and then like things weren't looking
good and i was like [ __ ] it i gotta
delete all my videos now it's just
[ __ ] up
so it's like eight at a time delete
eight at a time delete just seeing all
those videos like eight at a time delete
and i was like that hurts and there's no
way you
backed them all up sometimes you forget
yeah i literally posted on my story i
was like dude i cannot back up my videos
like i'm in the car on a trip like
please someone just like backed these up
and someone saved most of them
oh [ __ ] yeah which is clutch as [ __ ]
damn yeah super classy yeah through do
that yeah epic
great guy just a [ __ ] amazing guy and
i was like yeah i saved most of them so
that was cool
but yeah i had to delete them i was
insane and then i had to just like lay
low
wait for like the two-week band to be
over just like started fresh
that hurts it was [ __ ] up oh
yeah that's horrible having to delete
everything not even just getting delete
at least a whole nother thing
yeah it's well i mean i guess it's the
same [ __ ] thing at least you had the
chance
right which is definitely at least they
gave you the chance did you get multiple
strikes you should get deleted
out of nowhere no strikes no warnings
deleted
what you're telling [ __ ] me
you're telling us that's so [ __ ] up
that's it you're insane
no strikes no warnings deleted one day
the night we were about to hit him yeah
i was going to say the day you were
going to hit a million
holy [ __ ] oh no but have you seen this
we might be getting paid man whoa
youtube might be
monetizing cannabis content they said it
says who
i've watched i've already gotten two
people sending me the article uh one on
twitter one on instagram
i went to the link it looks completely
legit saying that i've seen this article
a bunch of times this is this is this is
a little different but look it might
relax on some rules about
uh ad on drug related videos right
so i saw a straight-up weed ad on
instagram bro i've been getting a lot of
those dudes
i'm like what the [ __ ] i screenshotted
like two of them because i was like no
way
no way youtube too so that's my next
change
youtube is now advertising weed [ __ ] on
you know
the [ __ ] ice cream commercial before
your youtuber
[ __ ] starts it's a weed ad because
they know what you're watching
yet you don't get paid i don't get paid
right
wow have you ever looked up the number
how much you would have gotten paid
oh dude it's the worst i try not to yeah
for sure i did like a year ago and i was
like i'm not gonna look anymore like
ever again
i looked it up over two-year coursework
yeah it was almost like bro
you bought a house hollywood dude
lots of views on months like just
nothing
yeah no it's so bad i mean like 30 cents
like thanks guys appreciate it google
one time i just had like
two thousand dollars dollars when i
first started go oh my god tube and i
was thinking this
reel and shop to like five and then it
just went d monetized
[ __ ] i should have dumped that money out
or i didn't know how it worked back then
so i didn't get it
but um yeah i'll see like one cent two
cent
gone the next day like why do you even
have my revenue
button open like what's the point yeah
but yeah if you google it and you google
the
oh man you see your name and you see how
much money you're supposed to make
it's like a fat range dude it's like 60
to 600 000 a month
it's like well i'll show you the biggest
i'll show you the one that's
precise it goes off to google and i mean
the youtube analytics and all the little
cpm [ __ ] like the exact [ __ ]
yes it hurts so bad that's [ __ ] up
so you're at least over a mil solid
legal million dollar money that's so
[ __ ] up
so we might get it what they start
allowing us
yeah they start allowing us to get paid
that'd be insane bro i wonder if
like i wonder if that's off the back of
something else i wonder if they know
something like these big corporations
they're like something we'll leave
soon 2022
yeah they're getting ready for it like
all these they they know they i bet they
have the insider on
whatever it's [ __ ] huge exactly they
got it all do you ever do the surveys at
the top of google oh youtube like take
your survey
do you ever do them no i do them all the
time so they're like you know what he
chipped in
i just wanted to like yo leave me the
phone the overlords
every time they ask you do something
like that oh of course
survey oh hispanic
what do you identify as male i'll do it
60 times if i have to
hey youtube leave us alone man yo you
get [ __ ] play you got deleted off
instagram you got it back
he got it back yeah that's not easy
twice how'd you get it back
the first time i did um i just like
spammed all those like uh yeah the
appeal had to [ __ ] take the picture
of myself and [ __ ]
isn't it so stupid it's goofy it's like
i have them in my
photo just over the course of how much
you can delete it you can see it like
yeah yeah and you have to put like both
hands exactly or they don't think it's
you or something
and your driver's license yeah but the
second time the craziest thing i didn't
even have to do that i just got
like just one day like i was looking at
it yeah i didn't even yeah it was
[ __ ] insane i looked at my profile on
another person's phone like what's your
backup account and i was like all right
i gave it to you
and i saw my real account like pop up
what the [ __ ] and i clicked it it was up
and i was like
what wow yeah it was insane [ __ ]
feeling
yeah it was an insane feeling bro i was
like there's no way bro i'm so
upset at instagram i just don't even
like care as much anymore it hurts so
bad [ __ ] it
we're on account 20 [ __ ] three yeah i
was gonna ask how many times
23 and i ate a cookie the other day god
talked about a collaboration i'm going
to do and they deleted the video and
goes we're probably going to delete your
account
your account may be deactivated here you
see that like oh
it's like maybe jesus that's
[ __ ] up so yeah ducing you get it back
the other day i was [ __ ]
tight like no way somebody won yeah i
know
bro it's like [ __ ] yes like you beat
the system yes ram will show you
somebody with their like head blown off
the bus
behind me
there's a girl i don't know if she still
got her page because i saw it on the
explore page
on the explore page there's a [ __ ]
skinny mexican like pretty mexican girl
and she hits [ __ ] chris in a pookie
like as she does her makeup and gets
ready and talks like vlogs
hitting a [ __ ] pookie pipe
like a meth pipe that's her writers
40 something thousand followers bro
right shouldn't it be instagram let it
happen i'm saying
they let her do [ __ ] but they won't let
me
tag my own legal companies that's
[ __ ] insane that is insane i have to
blur wheat out this bitch's hidden
[ __ ] crystal meth
they deleted it with the blurred weed
and yep with the blur we still deleted
my [ __ ]
she's doing her makeup though come on
for as long as we've been working
together you've never posted weed on
instagram
nope it's been clean over a year and
they still deleted it
it's all good though we're winning
[ __ ] instagram dude [ __ ] instagram
it's okay one day that's facebook it's
raises
when facebook bought a man mark
zuckerberg he's a little lizard guy
he's scary yeah i wanna say too much
he's scary though he creased me out i
saw the more they're giving him a
interview and he's just like when court
oh my damn
we look nervous what did you do i didn't
know what it was about wasn't
questioning his ass
right yeah oh that's why he looked
nervous okay i got you got you then you
were guilty cause if no someone's asking
me some [ __ ] like
i heard you're a piece of [ __ ] and
you're a thief ask away [ __ ]
what do you want to know
you're a liar damn dude i didn't know
they were questioning him because he
looked
i just saw the memes of him like
drinking water like a little nervous
yeah i think it's about like privacy
laws or something like facebook was
being invasive and the government was
like yeah what are you doing well
they're definitely listening to your
phone oh for sure every time they say
something it's the first thing that pops
up on my youtube search
oh my god oh my goodness or instagram
it's all right
[ __ ] pops up and i get an ad there's no
warnings now when you go to run an ad it
says with ios 14
be warned privacy settings have changed
and your ads aren't going to reach
nearly as many people
that's like all over the ad manager now
there's these banners wow
i'm assuming it's probably related to
this but right
i don't understand the internet
i just know how to make videos and put
them on there yeah i was going to say
that
that's as far as i know i learned come
on man
that's a crazy place you just explain
nft and cryptocurrency they're not brand
new
and i've heard them many times never
learned i learned what the republicans
and democrats were i think on the first
couple of episodes of this podcast all
right
that's the time i learned i don't give a
[ __ ]
no we sat here and just displayed how
much we don't know i think
yes thank you thank you that's that's
that's more what i should say
yeah dude i'm very ignorant i'm mad at
all i do is sell drugs
do you ever get that [ __ ] where
people are like bro are you not you're
not posting about this like
where's the activism at and i feel like
it's just like i want like
i want this like i want this page to be
like an escape for like from all that
i've said that and got attacked and then
i went i still believe
that yeah that i don't have to talk
about everything because why would i
have to
all right like don't make me feel guilty
for people's wrongdoings
speaking out about it just as bad it's
just as bad
are you far right [ __ ] you that's how i
feel like i know you get that [ __ ] too
dude
i get that [ __ ] all the time i know it's
so cool like i said it's so wildy
talk to somebody that knows exactly what
the [ __ ] i'm talking about
word for word it's so bomb
and now you just moved here to the
company
yo you sound exactly like me and i
[ __ ] love you
good i'm glad man because the first time
i met you i was like oh
sick
i like this and yeah man i'm glad you're
here i'm gonna smoke [ __ ] weed
yes yes i know it sounds like exciting
happiness
yeah let's see i've been in my house for
a year
it's cool to chill with some fools that
smoke weed dude it's so different in
texas everything was opened back up
had like oh you had a whole different
experience there's open clubs open
for the past few months that i was there
like everything was open just to pop in
restaurants been tied in since like
the end of last year like seven or seven
o'clock yeah what was it uh
are they are the cases up or down
they're down the cases are down
yeah so i think that's the thing in
floor or the two
most lax laws when it comes to covert
restrictions have the least are like are
seeing the biggest declines and people
are like
fauci was like i don't know what's going
on really yeah
i don't follow the new i don't get it
and i doctor fauci i know he's the
doctor
shut up i have no idea what he looks
like there's a little
doesn't even know what's going on he
said confused
not sure why oh it's down
and there's isn't there a shitload of
isn't it population high
it's it's a really like dense place for
sure there's like five super yeah i
think it's like the
top five most popular states for sure
it's the biggest state but i didn't know
about population yo so you're telling me
that the [ __ ] went down
yeah [ __ ] awesome i can't explain it
after nick's in the mountains all that
football
football barbecue yes that's what it was
about
um dude yeah
you know what let's do this let's take
dabs after
because i feel like we're just going to
be here
in people's ear while they're driving
let's take it after
um well dude i wanna i want you to tell
everybody
where can they find you at for the with
everything i wanna i wanna
um i know you have your
not not only like your stuff like aaron
constable i know you're you're
anova right okay yeah you can find me uh
aircon
just like look that up on uh it's a
little bit hard on instagram aircon
underscore you gotta type it in exactly
super shadow man people tell me that all
the time on youtube a little surprised
but
that's for sure yeah yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] definitely you play just as much
as i do
yeah oh good shot good picture i don't
even know you took that
no damn inception there it is
yeah there it is anova is the
uh brand that i have a nova dot ig you
have those dabbers right there that
shit's crazy tight
yeah the little uh turf slurper that
we're smoking on right now
oh that was them i mean that's them
that's your [ __ ]
yeah so that's from an artist you just
like basically by wholesale that's
right good [ __ ] method dude so all
these people are local artists in
america
just like doing their thing they have
super unique styles just highlighting
them
right so you're like this is from this
this week's this
is from this week just for like this
artist in this state that makes
specializing in these things so yeah
nova smoke is the website
nobody.com make sure you check it out
your
logo thank you thank you that's cool
yeah i got it from uh so i was sitting
in statistics class actually
and there's these things called the
anova tables and i was like i just kept
writing it down over in the [ __ ] over
in class and i was like dude this sounds
sick
and i started like a new page in the
journal i was like a nova and i started
like drawing the logo and everything i
still have that page
where it's like i just first sketched it
yep keep it forever dude
for sure because you can look back like
frame it
yeah 100 [ __ ] yeah whoa next drop
in yeah yeah and i have a little
countdown for you
that is so sick once you sell out of
your pieces it's done forever yeah
every monday 4 20 p.m there's a new drop
every [ __ ] monday every monday
what the [ __ ] you are active bro
and you're shipping and packing all this
yourself yeah good
tight yeah it's a good time yeah buying
all the stickers and everything and like
sending it up i got my homies doing it
with me and stuff and we just like
smoking this like pack it's fun as [ __ ]
honestly
that's great dude good [ __ ]
thank you thank you [ __ ] yeah no i
really like it like
your website looks awesome it's it's to
the point
you don't need all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that looks great it's right there it's
everything you need
just the product i [ __ ] with the mystery
boxes all those boxes over there mystery
boxes we just
we didn't made the fire i just i need to
do that marty can you please remind me
after the [ __ ]
need to make a fire um i love that great
good job man good [ __ ] you're on your
way to
to to getting your own [ __ ] going i love
that that's i appreciate it thank you so
much every monday at 4 20 you're
dropping something
oh you're nonstop man you know always on
the ground i'm so
fun times you were doing that and going
to school yeah that was going to be
too much yeah it was crazy china like
source it all the time you know what i
mean just wait
chill get ready and you have everybody
in your employees doing your [ __ ] go
back to school
right you know you can get your [ __ ]
started so by the time you're like
hitting 30 you're like
no i'm good yeah yeah yeah that's sick
man good [ __ ]
so eric con on everything anova dot ig
we'll put it in the um
description i don't know if we can even
tag your youtube channel that's a weed
youtube
it might be dude it's all right you can
find it on youtube
all right well uh hopefully it's
it'll it'll be there don't worry [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um thank you for coming man thank you
for coming and i know we
people like you guys take damn [ __ ] i
thought about it i think youtube's gonna
get upset
i think i think they're getting mad also
yeah we don't want blow torch in your
ear for everybody
too loud on august
there it is some exclusive dab content
no that's everything it's everything uh
if you go to yeah you get those.com you
go to um
to podcast every [ __ ] idea every
single thing yeah
dude the website's the best thing we
ever did we built it that's awesome
dude everything everything goes to it oh
yeah
nice yeah yeah
[Music]
thank you super hype for you man thank
you um thank you so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] here we go let's take more
dabs all right let's do something down
dude thank you thank you so much for
being here this would be
one of many i'm assuming guys i didn't
want to go too
long like marty told me of the day i
think we're gonna start leaving people
wanting more
you're right three to four hour podcast
or maybe we're getting everything out
you're right you're completely [ __ ]
right it's like episodes longevity
gotcha and that they're hard to edit it
took 23 [ __ ] hours to export and
upload
wow and you have to watch every single
second of it so it's like if it's a
three four already types on this
responsibility
we got the four camera angles gone
upload only upload a loans
yesterday just to upload wow
holy [ __ ] youtube 11 hours 11 [ __ ]
hours
i see you always have problems too yeah
oh dude this one youtube never been like
tomorrow upload it'll just be running
all day and [ __ ]
process and processing and it's like
crazy there's not a lot you can do for
it i know it's insane you just sit there
and feel so powerless you're like bro
come on i'm gonna leave too
i'm leaving you come back and upload it
it happens all the [ __ ] time
sorry i know our outros are the longest
things ever uh welcome to l.a i'm stoked
for you good [ __ ]
you got a lot of [ __ ] going i'm i'm
hyped guys this is eric khan thank you
so much you guys have been asking
non [ __ ] stops so here it is all
right it was fun let's take some more
dabs let's chill
thank you guys so much for watching this
has been another episode of the dope as
usual podcast
i'm dope ziola have a dope ass day
dude dude dude no more dabs right before
we start
first five minutes i was going huh [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right podcast nice
that cricket it was loud it stopped it
was
so [ __ ] loud though
yo it was in my ears do you think it's
like up there or something
dude i don't understand [ __ ] it's crazy
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
you